Our government's always
controlled our content.
The fight for freedom.
We've just never paid attention.
Freedom of speech.
There's a very small group of people,
that influence all the
companies that we watch.
That's why we have Q, patriots everywhere,
stand at the ready.
Q is completely baseless.
It's the rantings and
ravings of anonymous people
who we don't know,
it may be multiple people,
It may be different people,
It may be one person.
Q has not foretold anything
despite the fact that many
people who are believers in Q
will try to convince you through
different signals and small
things that you might not have picked up,
that it actually is all true.
You know, it's not true.
This is insane.
QAnon offers a constantly shifting way
to view the world as it's happening,
which means that it's very
easy for people who believe it,
to then discard any attempt to
reason with them and explain
why they shouldn't believe it.
It's almost seeped into the
groundwater of the internet now.
Google, lied to you!
Facebook, lied to you!
You know, for a long time reporters
have been trying and have
been openly wondering
who is Q?
Who is this anonymous
person making the posts.
It's one letter, but it spells out
a bizarre conspiracy theory
with President Trump at the center.
Obviously, the president
knows what QAnon is.
Well, I don't know much about
the movement other than I
understand they like me very much.
Almost equally, as important
as to whoever Q is,
is who runs these sites like
QMAP?
People like this are just
as influential in spreading the
conspiracy as Q themselves.
Q is a pretty interesting case study
in how you move a
fringe idea into the mainstream.
I had a personal curiosity
as to who was behind QMAP before.
You know, I really felt that it
warranted kind of a deeper investigation.
The place to start was
to go and talk to him.
So I rented a car and I
drove out to New Jersey.
My name is William Turton,
I'm a cybersecurity
reporter at Bloomberg News.
I'm Joshua Brustein,
I'm a writer for Bloomberg News
and Businessweek magazine.
I'm one of the two writers on
the story about QMAP.pub.
Jason Gelinas is a pretty
normal sounding guy.
He is a dad in New Jersey,
three children lives in Berkeley Heights,
which is a town about an hour
outside of New York City.
Jason, in many ways was
your typical American.
He got a degree,
he went into working in the
technology departments of
different banks.
He was a senior employee at
Citibank where he managed over a
hundred employees, and you know,
the last major project he worked on,
there was an artificial
intelligence project at Citi.
Jason Gelinas also ran one of the,
if not the biggest QAnon conspiracy website.
Like many people who are
now deeply into QAnon,
Jason seemed to express the
beginnings of interest in these
kind of theories during
the Obama administration.
We were able to speak to friends,
one of whom told us that, you know,
about the time Obama was elected,
Jason described Obama to
him as the antichrist.
He seemed to have a lot
of anger towards the Obama
administration and began to
explore some unconventional
shall we say beliefs.
One of them related to the idea that
Hillary Clinton was
involved in sex trafficking.
You know, we don't know for sure
if Jason believed in 'Pizzagate' as
it's formerly known,
but friends told us that he
believed in this idea that
powerful Democratic officials,
including Hillary Clinton
were involved in the sex
trafficking of children.
But this all goes back to
Russian hackers leaking John
Podesta's emails, you
might recall those were
posted on WikiLeaks and users on
the image board 4chan started
reading those emails and
decided that the word pizza
meant children and kind of
worked themselves up into this
idea that in the basement of
a pizza shop in DC, were secret tunnels,
leading to Congress, where
they're sex trafficking children.
One of the big surprises of
the presidential campaign was
the explosion of fake
news on the internet.
Fantastic tales that
some believe to be true.
At one point far into
the conspiracy theory,
someone actually showed up there with,
with an assault rifle and
shot it inside the restaurant.
Before realizing that the
basement he was looking for that
would have presumably held the
children did not even exist.
28-year-old Edgar Welch was
arrested in Washington
Sunday afternoon, outside Comet Ping Pong,
a popular family pizza parlor,
D.C. police say Welch fired
at least one round into the
restaurant floor with an
AR-15 rifle like this one
on his Facebook page.
He recently pleaded guilty,
but this became a huge phenomenon,
which kind of set the stage for QAnon.
So Q drops as they're called,
are posted to this
website called 8kun,
which is formerly called 8chan.
They were formerly posted on 4chan
and they can come daily,
a few days apart or multiple times a day.
In October 2017,
a anonymous user who called
themselves Q posted a message
saying that Hillary
Clinton would be arrested,
that this would lead to planned riots.
And that this would kind of be
the beginning of the apocalypse.
Now, this sounds really weird.
It wasn't actually all
that unusual for 4chan
at the time.
There were
a fair number of posts
from people purporting to
be high-level government
officials, revealing secrets,
and the QAnon account was one of them.
There was an FBIAnon,
there was a CIAAnon,
and for whatever reason,
this is the one that took off.
This is a movement where
you get information,
that's all it is.
It's up to you how you want
to take it, follow the plan,
trust the plan, the great awakening.
Yeah.
You know, there's a lot of reasons why
someone might believe in QAnon.
It actually, you know,
is why people believe in
conspiracies in general.
I think now more than ever,
there's kind of distrust in the media,
in this shared set of facts.
It's all about control.
Look at the science,
show me the science with a mask.
Because I show you science
the virus goes right through the mask.
The coronavirus probably
drove people deeper
into their kind of silos and their holes.
Many of the followers will
sometimes talk about how they've
been alienated from
their friends and family.
But they'll say,
you know, I have my Q family.
There are a handful of Q
aggregators, including QMAP,
which have taken the Q drops
and posted them in more
friendly web environments,
devoid of some of the pornography
and other things that are
on the websites where
the original Q drops are.
So QMAP was started in April 2018.
What QMAP did that was so interesting
was that it took it one step further.
Not only did it aggregate the posts,
it also kind of wrote out
these themes and players.
So, it was really easy to navigate.
And this to me was one of
the biggest revelations
in my reporting.
When we found deleted
posts from Jason Gelinas
where he explained on Twitter,
how he designed the site like
this intentionally to make it
as accessible to as many people
as possible, as he called it,
he was "onboarding normies
into the conspiracy."
You know, if you wanted
to read more about this
secret pedophile cabal, great.
Or if you want to read about
the secret plot to take down
Mike Flynn, for example,
Trump's former national
security advisor, boom.
There's a theme you can go
to and read all about it.
In recent weeks,
two researchers at this startup
in the UK called Logically
publish this really interesting
and fascinating report that
outed Jason as the person behind QMAP.
So Logically.ai is a small
operation that looks to expose
disinformation through
basically internet forensics.
We use a lot of data streams,
it's then up to us as the investigators
and the users to pair
that information down,
look for trends, look for patterns.
My name is Joe Ondrak.
I am the senior investigator
at Logically.ai.
We are primarily a
fact-checking company,
but we also do investigations
and editorial into
disinformation and misinformation online.
And they began looking into
QMAP in the late summer
because they felt like it was a way
that people were becoming radicalized
and wanted to figure
out who was behind it.
There was a URL with
an email address in it.
And from there, we were
able to find Google Chrome
store page for QMAP.pub.
And the QMAP app that he was
running that had since been
deleted by Google Play,
when they realized they were
starting to crack down on QAnon.
Because he was monetizing these apps,
he had to register them under
a company which led us to
Patriot Platforms LLC.
And obviously if he'd
registered for an LLC,
there would be filings with
names attached to it that we
could then explore.
So we pursued open business records,
we looked at those,
which gave us the name, Jason Gelinas.
I saw the report, I was like,
this is really interesting.
I mean, this is fascinating, but you know,
they hadn't gone to Jason
for comment, you know,
it was kind of just put
out there on the website.
The first thing I did was, I
rented a car and I drove out to
New Jersey and I found
Jason in his front yard.
He was holding a wheelbarrow
while some landscapers and
laborers around him were
doing work on the hedges
and the lawn,
and I felt really nervous.
I walked over and I said "Hi, Jason,
I'm a reporter from Bloomberg.
Just wanted to ask you about this report
that's been published that
says, that you run this website?"
He was a little evasive.
He kind of walked away from me
and I was able to kind of get
him to continue talking, but you know,
never denied running the site.
And eventually said that QMAP
was a patriotic movement to
save the country.
You know, eventually his wife
appeared to the front door
who kind of beckoned him inside.
I went and knocked on
his door a second time,
really in the effort to try and
give him as much opportunity
to comment or clarify as possible.
He didn't respond, once I was in my car,
multiple police SUV's
arrived and informed me that
Jason had called the police.
Once Jason knew he was found out,
he took down his entire
online presence as well as his
wife's online presence and pretty much
disappeared from the internet.
QMAP.pub also came down and
was basically just a couple of
links to other QAnon aggregators.
After our first article that came out
that noted Jason was an employee
at Citigroup, the company
placed him on paid leave.
It's unclear where Jason is now,
but Citi actually fired
Jason Gelinas after
almost 13 years at
the company.
The reason they gave for
firing him is that, you know,
working at Citi is a really
highly regulated place.
And you have to disclose
to the company, your,
your income outside.
And, you know, he was in theory,
making money off this QAnon website off Patreon,
and he never disclosed that to his company.
QMAP coming down will probably not
have a huge impact on the viability of
the QAnon community.
At this point,
it is large enough to be pretty adaptable.
You've seen it pop up
in many places overseas,
and it really serves as a sort
of proxy for extreme distrust
of any institutions.
And Q has served as a
pretty effective vehicle
for that kind of feeling.
"I stand before you tonight,
honored by your support."
I think it kind of goes back
to this idea that people are
disillusioned with kind of
what's happening in the world
that are more likely to
believe conspiracy theories.
I think that's what makes Q appealing.
It's finally an answer to
all of the weird and strange
things that are happening in the world.